our first wildflower of the season too
is well out of this world
diana trujillo is a nasa aerospace
engineer working on the perseverance
rover which is currently searching for
signs of life on mars
we caught up with her at the nasa jet
propulsion laboratory just outside of la
in pasadena california and i know that
you're going to be as blown away by her
and her backstory as we were there's a
lot about kind of school
uh in the theme of this show
so take a look at this
hello everybody we are coming to you
from a very special location we're on
mars
well actually we're on the simulation of
mars and we are here with our wildflower
deanna trujijo it's your backstory that
really inspires me you came here from
columbia at 17. that's correct what was
your fear
and what was your dream
my fear there was am i going to be able
to eat today am i going to be able to
have a shelter today where am i going
gonna sleep in my dream at the same time
was to survive when i was in colombia
and i was thinking that you know
everything around me was chaotic looking
at the sky was the place where i found
myself
what a beautiful thing to turn to
in such pain and chaos and fear
and the payoff is
we're here at nasa
you are a leading engineer i channelize
my grandma my great-grandma my mom and i
realized you know they really gave up
their education for the children it is
time for me to honor what they did for
me and also to show the men of my family
that women can do more than what they
think i remember myself asking what's
the hardest thing that a human can do
and then thinking i'm gonna do that oh
my gosh that's so cool i can't even
handle it i end up going to university
of florida and i told one of my
professors i want to work for nasa he
suggested that i applied to the nasa
academy and i remember looking at the
applications and i'm concerned because
you know english is my second language
and at that point i was not going to
send it and so my roommates ended for me
18 students got selected for the nasa
academy i was the only latin women in
that class i'm convinced that there are
literal angels because that teacher and
your roommate took that bold step for
you so i just want to encourage people
in life to help encourage other people
to take bold steps
you've made it now to nasa
what your position right now with
perseverance we're trying to answer
if there was life in the past it seems
like the party's over in mars like
everybody's kind of resting and chilling
that's right the coachella is not
happening on mars what happens if you
realize
okay there was life here before my
personal hope is maybe it would change
our perspective as humans as to how we
treat each other and how we treat our
home planet i mean
doing e.t when i was six years old is
not the impetus for my next comment but
i am convinced we're not the only ones i
agree
this is one of the rovers that we use to
understand certain things of mobility
mikey would you mind so this is
scarecrow why did you name it scarecrow
is it a wizard of oz
that's the big theme of our show this
year
this is our sister
rover the spare parts of the actual
perseverance rover this is the dry run
to make sure you're getting it right so
that when you execute it on mars you
have had your practice and you're going
in
really knowing what's gonna happen
exactly
wow
this is my war games fantasy
oh my god i thought i was about to go
through a hole in the floor but this is
not the center of the universe
from here we command
lots and lots of missions that are going
to different planets mars missions and
beyond this is my baby the robotic arm
on mars
diana you are making it your mission to
include the latinx
community what is it that you would like
to accomplish i want to
take down the expectation of what women
are supposed to be doing i have two kids
i'm married and i'm also doing this so
you get to do it all i don't think that
there is a bigger inspiration out there
than you diana thank you
you are truly
my hero
[Music]
you